don't run for me 60fps peasant phone
fortnight just released a brand new
update for iOS and iPad and on the 2018
iPad pro which we have right here it's
about one and a half years old right now
you can play at a hundred and twenty FPS
that's actually insane on the ps4 a pro
on the best Xbox out there you're
limited to 60 but with this iPad pro you
can go up to 120 fps so in this video
we're gonna show off some of that
gameplay we're actually gonna show some
slow-motion 120 FPS footage to show you
guys how much better it is than 60 and
we're also at 100% battery life right
now so we're gonna see how much battery
life it drains after one hour of
gameplay we're actually at 10:27 right
now so let's open fortnight right here
and right here you can see that we're at
120 fps right there we've got a show FPS
on you guys can see right down there 120
fps here you guys are we can see that
we're at a consistent one Sony fps is
not dropping below at all and everything
so far is just incredibly smooth it
almost feels like unrealistic I've
played at 60fps before with the
controller and I can tell you that if
you guys want to play fortnight on an
iPad or an iPad pro you need a
controller it's just so much better than
using the claw or hand controls or
anything like that
whoa what's up man is so nice with this
controller I'm crouching right now not
if you guys can see but now we get l3 in
our three controller support so the R 3
is actually crouching and the L 3 let's
see can actually do auto sprint so it's
sprinting automatically everything is
incredibly smooth oops someone's in here
Oh
got'em
yeah um yes oh he's in the bush so far
the performance has been insane
everything's perfectly smooth no matter
how many gun battles I've been getting
in and one thing I know is that when
this update came out people were
actually complaining because they were
saying that people with iPad pros the
2018 model get an unfair advantage and I
can actually see where they're getting
that from because it does make it super
smooth yeah uh Oh No reload whoa what's
up bro you missed every time come on
oh I missing
don't miss whoa whoo what's up man I see
I see where you at bro whoa look at that
bad oh this is great
you want to go - well dude why's
everybody try to kill me here leave me
alone so as you guys saw from all those
gun battles no drop friends at all
really reliable really smooth gameplay
it actually does helped her performance
in-game oh you got me don't run from me
60 FPS peasant phone yeah uh yes got him
cut someone's behind me - yes why didn't
you kill me dude
hahahaha what's up dude yes
got him I used to play mobile with just
finger controls and honestly I'd be
dying like all the time and I've never
played this good I'm not this good at
this game but with controller support
I'm just so much better so much easier
like this
oh I barely got him guys
oh come on
yes victory here I have a guy his that's
what I'm talking about controller
support 120 FPS it actually does give
you an unfair advantage this is insane
yes I see oh yes whoa in the base
alright guys so it's eleven twenty seven
exactly an hour of gameplay at 120 fps
and we are at 58% battery life where's
its duty
58% battery life so I think 120 fps does
definitely take more battery power than
60 even at medium settings so you can at
least play two full hours straight on
battery power alone before you grab your
charger which isn't that great but still
you're playing at 120 FPS that was that
guy's that was a lot of fun playing at
120 definitely super smooth crazy good
performance no dropped frames probably
the best fortnight experience you can
probably get some would argue with that
but you can't even get 120 FPS on
consoles so PC gamers can go beyond that
but still this is amazing for an iPad
pro that goes as low as six hundred and
fifty dollars on sale on Amazon which is
insane
so with that you guys can see 120 FPS
slow down look at all those frames that
you're getting this is just insane on
the iPad pro hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video if you did click that circle
about to subscribe and check out one of
those two videos right over there thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]